[Music]
Detroit's a shiny object right now a lot
of national attention reason why you're
sitting in my car right now the reality
is that's not going to last forever so
we have got to move move move just as
quickly as we can we have this national
attention
Detroit is looking shinier and this guy
the guy we just met in the car
dig blaskowitz he's a pretty happy guy
these days he runs a capital fund called
invest Detroit and today they're here
with the mayor in Detroit's West Village
neighborhood where they'll soon break
ground on a new set of rowhouse
apartments that look like this when it
comes to Detroit the story many
outsiders are familiar with is a city in
decay but that's changing invest Detroit
and other groups started aggressively
redeveloping the downtown and now
they've gathered millions more an
investment to develop three Detroit
neighborhoods that the city has
prioritized
as templates for future growth this is
the West Village one of their poster
child neighborhoods just for context
though Detroit is huge
142 square miles and the West Village is
tiny really tiny just over a dozen
blocks so back to Dave we asked Dave to
show us around some other sites in the
West Village and even though we
definitely embarrassed him
he just really wants to try it to come
back so he agreed future development
agnus tree beer garden dog park all
right are you killing me man that's
awkward man that is not right all right
so is Detroit just picking itself up by
its bootstraps well not quite
let me tell you about this investment
we're investing in infrastructure
building CDFIs and schools the m1 light
small business in a different way we
receive the morale of venture capital
long term to accelerate here's our JP
Morgan's 2014 investment breaks down 50
million dollars to capital projects like
the downtown sites that Dave helped
about 25 million to remove our restore
abandoned homes 12.5 million for what
they call workforce solutions 7 million
for small business growth and the
remaining 5.5 million to major
infrastructure projects a yeren to their
investment JP Morgan earmarked 3.5
million dollars specifically for loans
to minority-owned businesses in a city
where the majority of the population is
black and have had a hard time accessing
capital even during periods where
interest rates were at an all-time low
after the recession banks got the
bailout but then they wouldn't load
anybody any money unless you had a
stellar credit rating or a big cash cow
behind so you just put it out of your
mind
don't even go at this couple angel and
Martin got to $100,000 lines of credit
from one of JP Morgan's local partners
Detroit Development Fund and yeah their
electrical contracting businesses doing
a lot better now for JP Morgan a
low-interest loan of this nature is
categorized as an act of corporate
responsibility but they're very clear
that this isn't charity work they aren't
giving away the money and we are making
an investment in Detroit so it begs the
question why is a bank with over two
trillion dollars in assets making the
focus of their philanthropy work trying
to revitalize an entire city from
we asked JP Morgan's head of corporate
responsibility who is touring a skilled
manufacturing training city Detroit is
not growing and we're a big bank in
Detroit that's not a good thing for us
from a business proposition right in
other words if there's no money flowing
there's no banking to be done the Motor
City has basically been in decline for
decades the median household income is
just $25,000 2/5 of the city population
lives in poverty and the City Public
Schools are some of the worst performing
nationwide everyone seems to agree that
Detroit has a lot of problems and it's
gonna take a lot of money to fix these
problems but who should be responsible
for ponying up that money is a different
question
the expectation for a long time has been
that governments will solve these
problems
the fact is governments have less
resources and these problems are just
getting bigger chase says they're
handling this like they would any other
part of their business
looking at the data sending a lot of
staff to spend time in the city so we
went to City Hall to ask the mayor how
he feels about a big Bank stepping in
with a hundred million dollars they've
gone well we got a hundred million
dollars and I think I hope they're
making money off it
you know the Troy's coming back very
well and I hope it works out financially
for the bank and I know it's working out
very well for the city mayor Duggan said
Jen de brought the city out of
bankruptcy and created stability and a
clean slate for investments like JP
Morgan's but if we go back to the West
Village again a neighborhood that JP
Morgan invest Detroit and the city
prioritized and you look at the activity
that's happening there it's worth asking
are the millions of dollars that are
catalyzing new construction going to be
inclusive for everyone
West Village was never expensive until
now now this is the gentrification
everybody is moving in we call them
hipsters they know they can get the rent
out the hipsters this is Edith Ford
she's a native Detroiter and she runs
community engagement for Mac development
a Community Development Corporation that
targets the zip code that the West
Village sits in with this apartment
that's gonna be really different because
people they pay that much money for rent
as some pockets change quickly like the
West Village the challenge will be
making sure that everyone in the city
can catch up when the plants was popping
everybody had Escalade when Bill Clinton
was in office
everybody was popping the manufacturing
is gone so let's find something else to
replace that and let's get back to work
revitalizing Detroit's neighborhoods
we'll keep Dave busy for a while we said
we want to do 10 neighborhoods in 10
years so we're trying to create
templates that we could then you know
use in other places in the city
JPMorgan is halfway through its
five-year commitment to the city of
Detroit but a city is more than its
buildings when I say the city's our
partner they're our full partner
they're bringing tools to the game
they're bringing the sentence to the
game they're bringing disincentives to
the game all of those things are gonna
help us accelerate you know the
redevelopment of these neighborhoods
[Music]